I actually am pretty terrible at yoga
but I grew up watching my not blood
uncle Renji practicing yoga in his home
every day and let me tell you it don't
look like this
the goats love this more than the people
do that ghosts are having a lot more fun
between your night yoga today is a
massive industry in the United States
and it's a major part of leading a
healthy lifestyle for millions of
Americans and a fashion style for lots
of others and while we may all know that
ohm and must stay and maybe even chakra
reward somehow related to yoga the
actual history of how yoga came to the
United States spread across the world
and gave birth to millions wearing
Lululemon isn't as well-known hey guys
I'm Sunna and today I'm going to explore
the history of yoga in the United States
and ask your favorite question our yoga
classes cultural appropriation
appreciation or just late stage
capitalism yoga is a massive industry in
the United States one study found that
Americans spend sixteen billion dollars
a year on clothing equipment classes and
accessories it's also reported that over
thirty six million or 15% of Americans
had done their downward dog at some
point in the last six months over the
course of their lives that number
increases to twenty eight percent of
Americans and it's also everywhere in
pop culture unless you're planning to
move those hands down get them off me
even over
so how did a South Asian spiritual
practice dating back thousands of years
even get to America well say hello to
swami vivekananda the man credited for
introducing yoga to americans
Vivekananda came to Chicago in 1893 to
speak at the first-ever Parliament of
Religions Conference a meeting of faith
leaders from around the world that was
part of the Chicago World's Fair he's
credited for having introduced Hindu
spirituality to Americans through a
series of speeches he gave at the
conference dr. Andrea Jain who focuses
on the popularization of yoga around the
world says that while the book ananda
made yoga better known in the united
states there were others who were
already dabbling in it before him many
americans appropriated yoga and
practiced it as a part of their
spiritual traditions long before that
they appropriated of course modern
versions of yoga yoga that they thought
were non dogmatic and oftentimes removed
from religious institutions and
Vivekananda wasn't even the guy who
popularized the kind of yoga we do today
in classes bks a younger kaepa to be
joyce and tkv this guitar are credited
for being the founding fathers of modern
yoga all three were students are perhaps
the most influential yoga teacher shri
Thermolite krishnamacharya among
krishnamacharya as most influential
students was Indra Devi Indra Devi was
key in teaching yoga in a way that
distanced it from those stereotypes of
Hinduism that many Americans deemed
threatening especially specific Hindu
beliefs that might be perceived as a
threat to American religious identities
in there o Devi whose real name was
Eugenie Pierson was a Russian actress
who brought yoga with her to Los Angeles
in 1947 where it attracted the attention
of actors interested in fitness and
breathing techniques I want to mention
here that from the 1880s into the early
1900s in response to the fear of
incoming immigrants the US government
enacted a series of immigration laws
that barred or limited immigration from
Asia and yoga in particular was treated
as a strange cult that was stealing
young white women and it's following
this period that we see Indra
Davee a white woman teach yoga now while
there were many Westerners traveling to
India for access to knowledge of yoga
and Hindu spirituality it's only after
the immigration Nationality Act of 1965
that we see yoga become a part of the
American counterculture of the 1960s
Hindu spirituality or spirituality from
the east was big and there were many
Swami's who were able to immigrate to
the United States and open up centers
and develop the practice and many young
Americans in search of spiritual
fulfilment continue to travel to India
Jain notes in our conversation that
Hindu spirituality was seen as an
outright rejection of the rigidity of
the church most of them were Protestant
Christians and they were rejecting the
church and instead turning to what they
considered to be radically alternative
in the 70s and 80s the growth of yoga
slowed down a bit and that lack of
growth coincided with a national
conservative movement and it's backlash
against counterculture but then the 90s
came and there was also boom and
corporatized everything including yoga
the 90s is when you start to see yoga
represented in the mainstream as is just
another consumer product that one could
buy just like an aerobics class one
could choose to go attend a yoga class
and part of that mainstreaming was
yoga's popularity among celebrities like
sting Raquel Welch Madonna Gwyneth
Paltrow and actress slash fitness guru
Jane Fonda be conscious of how relaxed
you feel
[Music]
carry this feeling with you one of the
most popular yoga books of the early
2000s by the way was my super model
Christy Turlington who was also featured
on Time magazine's cover for a story on
the science of yoga soon the instructors
to the stars like Baron baptise and
Rodney he became more mainstream
celebrities themselves so back to that
pesky question its practicing yoga if
you're not part of Hindu or even South
Asian culture actually a form of
cultural appropriation or is it
appreciation I actually got to sit down
with badass bay area artists John Buck
though who in 2014
put together an exhibit at the San
Francisco Asian Art Museum called
hashtag white people doing yoga buck
does exhibit looked at who got the face
time in the marketing and teaching of
yoga in the United States and spoiler
and wasn't Indians my practice revolves
around or focuses on identity politics I
started coming across grassroots level
like meditation and yoga ephemera from
like books records advertisements from
the 50s to the 80s and I was kind of
curious on how yoga was being branded
and marketed to the Western audience I
don't have the answers and I think
that's why I like I created the piece to
like really just explore that and see
what conversations come out of it Jane
is also quick to point out that the
appropriation conversation shouldn't be
so simplified that yoga's own history in
South Asia isn't linear we don't want to
perpetuate some kind of very simple
narrative that suggests that you know
there is this authentic original
tradition called yoga that existed in
South Asia that was then appropriated
yoga is really culturally South Asian it
doesn't belong to this religion or that
a lot of the problem also for Jane comes
down to how yoga is sold there are many
countless cases in which entrepreneurs
and corporations sell yoga products and
services and do so in a way that is
driven toward making a profit without
benefiting the conduits of yoga in South
Asia that said to just reduce the yoga
industry to mere commercialization or
modification is just too simple because
among many yoga practitioners you have
an interest in learning about that
history but despite how some
practitioners may have the knowledge
about yoga's history and the power
dynamics at play
the commercialization has nevertheless
whitewashed the practice in a two-yard
Havel study of Yoga Journal magazine
there was never a South Asian person on
the cover and less than 1% of content
contributors were South Asian and it's
not really surprising when yoga for the
most part of its history has been
marketed to white wealthy Americans I
think it's a extension of colonialism in
a lot of ways of mining mining the lands
and the cultures and then using those
materials for your own financial benefit
Shahrukh also pointed out how the
founder of Lululemon the leading name in
yoga apparel actually made a comment in
2004 in an interview about how he chose
the name for the company because it was
funny to hear the Japanese try to
pronounce it white male like making fun
of one Asian culture mining the fat of
another culture and just make and
sitting on billions of money and you
start seeing this pattern of like oh
yeah this sounds familiar and Jain notes
that while many yoga consumers may
actually be searching for something
spiritual the yoga industry functions on
while a sort of exotic ization of that
spirituality even though we oftentimes
think of commercial yoga as non
spiritual or non religious or simply
fitness or simply commodities it's a lot
more complicated because many of the
reasons behind why consumers choose yoga
are tied to Orientalist
stereotypes so when entrepreneurs then
sell these products they are
capitalizing off of those stereotypes
this whole conversation on appropriation
and authenticity takes an uncomfortable
turn when we look at how yoga has been
weaponized in India under the leadership
of Narendra Modi and the Hindu
nationalist BJP party they've been
trying to reclaim yoga as a Hindu
tradition as a way to assert Hindu
identity in a multi-religious country
where Muslims have come under violent
threat so how should we approach our
yoga classes is it time to drop the Sun
Salutations and incredibly comfortable
pants well I'll leave that to buffa I
guess what I want people to take away
is to just really stop and think about
what they're stepping on and you know
what they're participating in when
either going to yoga class or buying
those yoga pants hey guys hope you
enjoyed the video we by the way didn't
even get to touch on the fact that there
is a global tourism industry that is
centered on yoga or the yoga itself is
being commercialized in India but let us
know what you think in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe and come back
next Sunday